let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about partial fraction expansion or
sometimes it's called partial fraction
decomposition partial fraction expansion
expansion the whole idea is to take
rational functions in a rational
function is just a function or
expression where it's one expression
divided by another and to essentially
expand them or decompose them into
simpler parts and the first thing you
got to do before you can even start the
actual partial fraction expansion
process is to make sure that the
numerator has a lower degree than the
denominator and the the situation the
the problem that I've drawn right here
I've written right here that's not the
case the numerator has the same degree
as the denominator so the first step we
want to do to simplify this and to get
it to the point where the numerator has
a lower degree than the denominator is
to do a little bit of algebraic division
and I've done a video on this but it
never hurts to get a review here so to
do that we divide the denominator into
the numerator to figure out the
remainder so we divide x squared minus
3x minus 40 into x squared minus 2x
minus 37 so how many times you look at
the highest degree term so x squared
goes into x squared one time one times
this whole thing is x squared minus 3x
minus 40 and now you want to subtract
this from that to get the remainder and
see if I'm subtracting so I'm going to
subtract and then minus minus that's a
plus plus and then you can add them
these cancel out minus 2x plus 3x that's
X minus 37 plus 40 that's plus 3 so this
expression up here can be re-written as
let me scroll down a little bit as 1
plus X plus 3 over x squared minus 3x
minus 40 it's important key this might
seem like some type of magic thing I
just did but this is no different than
what
you did in the fourth or fifth grade
where you learned how to how to convert
improper regular fractions into mixed
numbers
if I had let me just do a little side
example here if I had 13 over 2 and I
want to turn it into a mixed number what
you do you probably do this in your head
now but what you did is you divide the
denominator into the numerator just like
we did over here 2 goes into 13 you say
2 goes into 13 6 times 6 times 2 is 12
you subtract that from that you get a
remainder of 1 2 doesn't go into 1 so
that's just the remainder so if you
wanted to rewrite this it would be the
number of times the denominator goes
into the numerator that's 6 plus the
remainder over the denominator plus 6
plus 1 over 2 and when you did it in
elementary school you just write 6 and
1/2 but 6 and 1/2 is the same thing as 6
plus 1/2 and that's exactly the same
thing we did here the denominator went
into the numerator one time and then
there was a remainder of X plus 3 left
over so it's 1 plus X plus 3 over this
expression now we see that the numerator
in this rational expression the
numerator does have a lower degree than
the denominator right the highest degree
here is 1 the highest degree here is 2
so we're ready to commence our partial
fraction decomposition and all that is
is taking this expression up here and
turning it into two simpler expressions
where the denominators are the factors
of this lower term so given that let's
factor this lower term so see what two
numbers add up to minus 3 and when you
multiply them you get minus 40 it's a C
they have to be different signs because
when you multiply them you get a
negative so it has to be minus 8 and
plus 5 so we can rewrite this up here as
I'll switch colors 1 plus X plus 3 over
X plus 5 times X minus 8 right 5 times 8
is minus 45 times negative 8 is minus 40
plus 5 minus 8 is minus 3 so we're all
set now I'll just focus on this part
right
now we can just have we can just
remember that that one is sitting out
there out front this is the expression
we want to decompose or expand we're
going to expand it just to simpler
expressions where each of these are the
denominator and I will make the claim
and if if though if the numbers work out
then the claim is true
I'll make the claim that I can expand
this or decompose this into two
fractions where the first fraction is
just some number a over the first factor
over X plus five plus some number B over
the second factor over X minus eight
that's my claim and if I can solve for a
and B in a way that it actually does add
up to this and I'm done and I will have
hat fully decomposed this fraction I
guess is the way I don't know if even
that's the correct terminology so let's
try to do that so if I were to add these
two terms what do I get when you add
anything you find the common denominator
and the common denominator the easiest
common denominator is to multiply the
two denominators so let me write this
here so a over X plus five plus B over X
minus eight is equal to well let's get
the common denominator it's equal to X
plus five times X minus 8 and then the a
term we would a over X plus five is the
same thing as a times X minus eight over
this whole thing right I mean if I just
wrote this right here and you just
cancel these two terms out and you would
get a over X plus five and then you
could add that to get the common
denominator X plus 5 times X minus eight
and it would be B times X plus five
right important to realize that look the
this term is the exact same thing as
this term if you just cancel the X minus
eight out and this term is the exact
same thing as this term if you just
cancel the X plus five out but now that
we have an actual common denominator we
can add them together so we get let me
just write the left side here over a
over X plus five oh sorry I know I want
to write
this over here I want to write X plus 3
over X plus 5 times X minus 8 is equal
to is equal to the sum of these two
things on top a times X minus 8 plus B
times X plus 5 all of that over their
common denominator X plus 5 times X
minus 8 so the denominators are the same
so we know that this when you add this
together you have to get this so if we
want to solve for a and B let's just set
that equality we can ignore the
denominators so we can say that X plus 3
is equal to a times X minus 8 plus B
times X plus 5 now there's two ways to
solve for a and B from this point going
forward one is the way that I was
actually taught when you know in the
seventh or eighth grade which tends to
be take a little longer then there's a
fast way to do it and it never hurts to
do the fast way first if you want to
solve for a let's pick an X that'll make
this term disappear so what X would make
this term disappear well if I say X is
minus five then this becomes zero and
then the B disappears so if X is if we
say X is minus five I'm just picking an
arbitrary X to be able to solve for this
then this would become minus five plus
three let me just write it out minus
five plus three is equal to a times
minus five minus eight let me just write
it out minus five minus eight plus B
times minus five plus five and I pick
the minus five to make this expression
zero so then you get pick a brighter
color minus five plus three is minus two
is equal to what is this minus thirteen
a plus this is zero right
that's zero minus five plus five zero
zero times B is zero and then you divide
both sides by minus 13 you get well
negatives cancel out you get two over
is equal to a and now we can do the same
thing up here and get rid of the a terms
by making X is equal to 8 if X is equal
to 8 you get X plus 3 is equal to 11 is
equal to a times 0 a times 0 plus B
times what's 5 8 plus 5 is plus B times
13 if there B looks a bit like a 13 and
then you get 11 is equal to 13 B divide
both sides by 13 you get B is equal to
11 over 13 so we were able to solve for
our A's and our B's and so we can go
back to our original equation and we
could say wow this just has to be equal
to 2 over 13 and this just has to be
equal to 11 over 13 so if I have if I so
this our original our very original
thing we wrote up here can be decomposed
into one that's this one over here Plus
this which is 2 over 13 I'll just write
it like this for now 2 over 13 over X
plus 5 you could bring the 13 down here
if you want to write it so you don't
have a fraction over a fraction plus
plus 11 over 13 plus 11 over 13 times
over X minus 8 and once again you could
bring the 13 down so you don't have a
fraction over a fraction but we have
just successfully decomposed this pretty
I don't you know I don't want to say
that we necessarily simplify it because
you could say oh we only have one
expression here now I have three but
I've reduced the degree of both the
numerators and the denominators and you
might say well Sal why would I ever have
to do this and you're right in algebra
you probably won't but this is actually
a really useful technique later on when
you get to calculus and actually
differential equations because a lot of
times it's much easier and I'll throw
out a word here that you don't
understand to take the integral or the
antiderivative of something like this
then something like this and later when
you do inverse Laplace transforms and
differential equations it's much easier
to take an inverse
applause transform of something like
this then something like that so anyway
hopefully I've given you another toolkit
in your or another tool in your tool kit
and I'll probably do a couple more
videos because we haven't exhausted all
of the examples that we could we could
show for partial fraction decomposition